Katrina:  太简单了
Katrina: Too easy.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:就学完了是吧
Jake: So, you've finished learning, right?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Lucia: 他们已经这个顺利学会了
Lucia: They've already learned this smoothly.
Shure: 觉得这个没有难度
Shure: They think it's not difficult.
Alice:会了
Alice: Got it.
Shure: 我们需要学学有一点东西的东西
Shure: We need to learn something with a bit more substance.
Shure: 哎我的b站又烂掉了
Shure: Ugh, my Bilibili is broken again.
Lucia: 这个我也复习起来能快一点
Lucia: If I review it, I can be quicker.
Jake:再看一下
Jake: Take another look.
Katrina: worth it的感觉是很早很早前的舞了
Katrina: "Worth It" feels like a dance from a long time ago.
Shure: 呦
Shure: Yo.
Katrina: 高中的时候就跳
Katrina: I danced it in high school.
Shure: 你还没有开
Shure: You haven't started it.
Lucia: 对对我那会大一的时候跳的
Lucia: Yes, I danced it in my freshman year.
Jake:你没开
Jake: You didn't start it.
Lucia: 所以其实也忘得差不多了
Lucia: So, I almost forgot most of it.
Lucia: 但是比学个新的能快一点
Lucia: But it's faster than learning something new.
Katrina: 所以
Katrina: So...
Katrina: 呃我想想本来备选还有什么来着
Katrina: Uh, let me think about what other options we had.
Katrina: 奔跑的青春和
Katrina: "Running Youth" and...
Lucia: 哎奔跑青春可以让他们去跳那个solo
Lucia: Hey, "Running Youth" can have them do the solo.
Jake:再跳吧
Jake: Dance again.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:啊你要干嘛了
Jake: Oh, what are you going to do?
Shure: 要脱光膀子了是吧啊
Shure: Are you going to take off your shirt?
Jake:你要脱了是吧哦
Jake: You're going to strip, right?
Katrina: 那就跳这个黑色的
Katrina: Then let's dance this black one.
Katrina: 哎为什么声音这么小
Katrina: Hey, why is the sound so low?
Jake:声音可以弄大一点
Jake: The sound can be turned up a bit.
Katrina: 我我已经调到最大了
Katrina: I've already turned it up to the maximum.
Katrina: 对这是教学
Katrina: Yes, this is the tutorial.
Katrina: 真假哈哈惊呆了
Katrina: Really? Haha, I'm shocked.
Shure: 哎呀卧槽
Shure: Oh my God.
Jake:好了哦行
Jake: Alright, okay.
Shure: 太sex了吧这个
Shure: This is too sexy, isn't it?
Katrina: 这正常的绝世元素
Katrina: This is a normal, absolute element.
Jake:来也跳啊
Jake: Come on, jump!
Jake:你们跳一跳
Jake: You guys, jump!
Lucia: 哎怎么又校准一次
Lucia: Hey, why calibrate it again?
Jake:因为刚刚有没有开
Jake: Because it wasn't on earlier.
Katrina: 刚开始是背过去的23456
Katrina: At first, it was turned the other way around.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: I see.
Alice:哎把这个往后推一推
Alice: Hey, push this back a bit.
Shure: 哪一部我不会了
Shure: Which part? I don't know anymore.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 等一下这个是
Lucia: Wait, this is...
Katrina: 你不是要跳
Katrina: Aren't you going to jump?
Shure: 买喽买喽买喽
Shure: Buy, buy, buy!
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:薇薇你没开
Jake:你没电了吗看一下
Jake: Are you out of battery? Check it.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Jake:right
Jake: Right.
Jake:对这是一个15156
Jake: Yes, this is a 15156.
Shure: 行了这
Shure: Alright, this...
Katrina: music
Katrina: Music.
Nicous: 快点的快点的
Nicous: Hurry up, hurry up.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 1234567822345678323456784234567耶
Shure: 1234567822345678323456784234567 Yay!
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Ouch.
Shure: 洒洒水
Shure: Just a little splash.
Katrina: 一辈子
Katrina: For a lifetime.
Shure: 三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Three four five six seven eight two two three four five.
Shure: 六七八三二三四五
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four five.
Shure: 六七八四二三四跑
Shure: Six seven eight four two three four run.
Shure: yes OK
Shure: Yes, OK.
Shure: 二三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight two two three four five.
Shure: 六七八三二三四顶
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four top.
Shure: 二四二三四
Shure: Two four two three four.
Lucia: 我们已经自动有了代教老师了
Lucia: We automatically have a substitute teacher now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 一二三四
Shure: One two three four.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Shure: 是不是武士就是都是这个样子
Shure: Are all warriors like this?
Lucia: 我好热啊
Lucia: I'm so hot.
Katrina: 哈哈突然把屁股顶了出去
Katrina: Haha, suddenly stuck my butt out.
Shure: 56
Shure: 5 6
Shure: 5678
Shure: 5 6 7 8
Shure: 12345678
Shure: 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8